Minister thank you for talking to us
you've just had a I guess it's kind of a
promotion your department just got a lot
bigger
more responsibilities because I'm
picking up the business facing aspects
of the former base department and we'll
talk about that in a second but but for
the time being we're here in Italy
you've announced a partnership I think
it's called
what difference in practice will that
make because a lot of people might look
at that and say you know it's not
changing Towers it's not changing custom
rules it's not changing any of the kind
of big substantive stuff so it kind of
accounts for basically nothing does it
um it does count for something one of my
top five priorities my top priority is
reducing Market access barriers and what
this kind of partnership allows is a
framework to problem solve so no we're
not changing taxes or regulations but
quite a lot of the problems that
business brings to me uh certainly from
the international trade perspective is
the differences in terms of how people
do business Customs issues and so on
that are not necessarily written in text
or in legislation but are still creating
barriers which we can bring down and
they're on both sides so in the same way
that we have issues doing business uh
with Italy Italians also have some
issues dealing with the UK so this is a
framework for us to solve those problems
perhaps on a case-by-case basis but
perhaps sectorally it depends on what
the issue is so we're talking to some of
the chief Executives one of the things
they keep saying is there are barriers
and there are barriers a lot of them are
self-imposed because of brexit and
things have got worse for them in terms
of trade that's that's kind of a fair
assessment isn't it some of them are
some of them are with any change you
will have pluses and minuses and when we
left uh the European Union we wanted to
have an independent reading policy that
has brought a lot of benefits in terms
of things that I can do now with the WTO
we have an independent seat there I'm
able to reduce a lot of Market access
barriers faster and more quickly than I
would have been able to uh or rather we
as a country would have been able to if
we'd been in the EU but yes there are
new barriers that have come up many of
them are not actually in the text of the
agreement it's about now having to
figure out how different countries
interpret the rules and make sure that
they do so in a way which helps our
businesses uh trade with them and their
businesses trade with us because I mean
you know how do you react when you hear
and it's we hear it a lot more and we
see it in the polling people getting
really frustrated a sense of regrets
um brexit isn't going very well is it
well I think this is one of the this is
one of the reasons is why I'm here we
spend so much time having an argument
about whether we should have left or
stayed in that took up many years you
know an entire parliament in one case
but we haven't actually spent enough
time talking about what we can do with
having an independence trade policy so
I'm not surprised a lot of people are
feeling regret because there are many
other sort of economic background facts
there's nothing to do with brexit which
make the which can make people feel
Bleak what I'm trying to do is they're
getting it wrong
no no that's not what I said what I've
said is that it is one factor there are
some advantages there are some
disadvantages what I'm here to do is
look at where new barriers have come up
because we've let and try and remove
them this is what having an independent
trading policy looks like this is what
happened when we were in the EU it's
just that we didn't do it ourselves it
was done at EU commission level now we
do it ourselves and we need to make sure
that we can reduce those barriers but
also remember that the EU is one trading
partner America the USA is our biggest
individual trading partner I do a lot of
Market access barrier removal work there
as well as with the rest of the world
and also I'm able to do things like uh
signed trade negotiations which I'm
working on with India and also with the
many countries in the uh cptpp we're
here in Italy though and you know how
would you say Italian trade with Italy
has gone over the last few years would
you say since brexit it's it's art pool
would you say it's gone down
um I uh as I understand it it has gone
up certainly in uh in today's figures we
are trading more overall it's gone down
it's um the figures that I have are that
we have 330 billion uh in terms of UK EU
trade that is something that has gone up
with Italy it's kind of down by about 12
or 16. well it also is looking at it it
exactly it depends on what you what
you're looking at are you looking at it
it's always down you need to finish the
you need to finish um the sentence
depends on whether you're looking at it
by volume it depends on whether you're
looking at it by value it also depends
on which inflation figures you are
applying and as we have said trade with
the EU is impacted by many things not
just brexit pandemic it's been impacted
by a labor market issues across the
continent not just in the UK it's been
impacted by the war in UK Russia gas
prices there's so much that is creating
a more difficult trading environment so
my job is to make sure that we are
working in order to make things better
what I can't do is get in a time machine
and go back into the EU and what I find
frustrating is that we spend loads of
time loads of time trying to relitigate
brexit rather than focus on solving new
issues that are coming up that's what
I'm here to do I'm not here to go back
to 2017 2019 and do that we wasted so
much time and I'm not here to waste time
I'm here to fix problems for business
having a long discussion around oh but
it was better with this year and not
that year and it's gone up and it's gone
down it is the long-term Trend that I
need to work towards rather than what
happened this year last year I think
that that is actually it's it's what I
would call a fake conversation it's like
asking people who just got married
where's the baby where's the baby some
things will take time and some things uh
will happen quickly we lost a lot of
time during the pandemic we lost a lot
of time with squabbling now we have a
new government that is actually focusing
on delivering for the British people and
the Prime Minister had the five
priorities which you know the second is
growing the economy he has now created
an economic growth Department by merging
uh business with trade and I'm here to
deliver on that and that's really
interesting so you see your department
you talked in your leadership bid about
cutting you know kind of having the
treasury and then having an economic
growth department so that's what you
view your current your new role as being
very much it's the department for
economic growth ultimately yes it's
really interesting because that's you
know that
it it it's kind of a slightly different
kind of version of changing Whitehall
than the version I think you were
talking about which was that the
treasury had become too powerful well no
it wasn't uh the point I was making
wasn't that the treasury had become too
powerful but it was it was a wider
argument about how much the state does
the treasury is so focused on all of the
other macros stuff that the economic
growth uh bit of it uh which was what I
was a minister for remember I was the
extra secretary in the treasury uh just
seemed to always be the Cinderella in
the in the department and I thought well
it'd be probably better if somebody else
was just doing this separately it wasn't
so much about breaking up the treasury
but making the focus of economic growth
another unit's priority and I think by
bringing uh dit and bees as they were
into one Department it's now very clear
who is doing that part of the difficulty
though is that you're not selling taxes
in the same way you know the treasury
seem really keeps control of that and do
you think at the moment that we have the
right right kind of balance of taxes and
spending in this country to try and
Achieve that growth in terms of what is
what it now yes I think
it's very easy to make cases for cutting
taxes all the time it all depends on
which side of the Laffer Curve you're on
at the moment what we need to do is
demonstrate uh that we have a sound
economy and we are operating on sound
money principles whether that means
taking two percent up here or there or
what you do with Corporation tags or
capital gains and so on those are
treasury matters what I'm here to do is
look at our wider business Award of
business and trade policy what are we
doing on investments what are we doing
to encourage companies to come here some
of that will be taxed but tax is not the
whole story we talk about taxes if it's
a silver bullet that will fix everything
it's not there's a lot more that needs
doing supply side reforms deregulatory
reforms and when we talk about
deregulatory reforms we don't mean
taking away people's rights we mean
making sure that the regulation we have
is fit for the economy that we want a
couple of things though so so these are
obviously you're going to get your teeth
stuck into them in the coming months I
imagine but the steel sector for
instance that is a big part of the job
of the business department
do you is your instinct that come what
may the UK needs to have a steel
industry even if it has to support it in
future or is that not necessarily a
given um not
ever nothing is ever a given it's
possible
deal from two different angles you can
look at steel from a local industry
perspective that this is something which
provides jobs to particular communities
and we wanted to survive thrive and grow
in the UK you can look at it in the
context of what is happening
internationally with China and other
players making so much steel that we
can't really control the price in the
market which means that it still needs
subsidies and you can also look at it
from the perspective which I've been
looking at it from an international
trade in terms of tariffs and WTO
trading rules there's a big bigger
picture around steel Beyond should we
just uh save this particular company or
help this particular community and that
is where working across Whitehall makes
a a real big difference it is good to
now have all of the policies sitting in
one department but I've also just been
doing the business rule for a day so I
understand it a lot more from the
international trade perspective and the
multilateral trading system
wwto rules Etc now I need to sit down
and look at what exactly has been going
on with steel uh from a business
perspective and an industry perspective
so specifically one question on trade
are you are you happy with the kind of
the the range of different trade deals
that you've inherited because a lot of
them you know you did inherit are you
happy with with say New Zealand are you
happy with Australia Georgia used to
said that the best thing about the
Australia deal is that you could is that
basically you could throw it out if you
wanted to I mean is that do you do you
buy that
um that is not the best thing about the
Australia deal uh the best thing about
the Australia deal is it's actually a
forward-looking free trade agreement it
is a good deal it's one of the first
ones we've done you do you do like it I
do like it certainly uh from what I've
seen going through uh the trade bill
which we've been taking through
Parliament for both Australia and New
Zealand and I think the challenge that
we have with deals like Australia New
Zealand where those are economies that
are predominantly or certainly in a very
large way dominated by agriculture is
that our agricultural sector looks at it
from a competitive angle so I'm an MP
for Rural constituency and I know what
farmers are going through and it's
really important that we let Farmers
know that we have their backs but we are
primarily a Services economy and the
trade deals are not just about selling
uh Dairy and buying beef and so on and
so forth and I uh I think the challenge
I would make to people like George
Eustis is that we can't keep talking
about other countries as if we only want
to sell to them and don't want to buy
anything that they have got trade is
something that benefits both parties
it's not a zero-sum game or something
where you're taking from from one party
and and there's a loose loser and that's
why I think it's a good deal because it
provides Mutual benefit to both
countries well one of the question that
on your new kind of department for
growth
if growth is really important do you
where does Net Zero fit into that is is
it still something that is potentially
an impediment to growth because you've
talked about that you've referred to
that in the past it yes it depends on
how you you carry out the policy you can
have a net zero policy that generates
growth and you can have a net zero
policy that bankrupts you and you need
to think very carefully about what it is
you're putting in place in order to make
sure that you have the positive outcome
not the negative outcome so my challenge
to many people who talk about uh Net
Zero and growth as if it's just a given
is that they need to really think
through what they're doing from first
principles rather than just uh you know
make talk about platitudes of green jobs
and so on what are we going to do with
this new Industrial Revolution is it
going to be like the internet in which
case we need to get in early in some
areas but we also know that there will
be winners and losers I remember the.com
boom and the time uh you know I remember
everybody putting lots of money into
companies that ended up going nowhere so
being very careful about what we invest
in and make sure that it's something
that's going to derive benefits being
quite hard nose looking at business
cases is a really key
um is really key do you think Joe
Biden's got the right balance on that
because you know the inflation reduction
acts this enormous piece of legislation
in the U.S uh it's it's hundreds of
billions of dollars
it doesn't feel at the moment first of
all that's a lot of money being spent
it's potentially going to have a big
impact here we can see that potentially
some green investment is going to leak
away from here
it doesn't feel like we actually have a
strategy or a policy yet on that I mean
do we have policy on this we well we we
are still in a place where the policy
from the US is being developed but what
I would say about the inflation
reduction Act is the protectionism only
works if one person does it if
everybody's doing it then we will become
losers so if the response so the
protectionist is it well well I think
subsidizing uh I've written I've written
publicly about this and I've written to
uh my trade counterpart in the US I've
been there multiple times now spoken to
representatives in the government and
they've said so they've heard what I'm
about to say this this isn't anything
new but if you subsidize industry to an
extent that it damages your allies it
affects Supply chains it creates single
points of failure it actually makes
Allied countries more vulnerable to
those other countries who we do see uh
more threatening as more threatening
economically and what our strategy has
been is to try and work with lots of
countries who are in the same position
that we are that includes the EU but
also countries like Japan countries like
South Korea Switzerland Australia New
Zealand these are many of them are
countries that are in cptpp but these
are countries who are like the UK they
have strong economies they are very well
developed and they have a global Outlook
in terms of making sure the supply
chains are Diversified what does it mean
if we all start subsidizing our
Industries some of us will lose money it
won't pay off for others who's going to
win who's going to lose and there are
some people who are a better place than
others to take advantage of it so even
within the EU the EU may speak as one
voice but actually there are some
countries who would benefit in the EU
from having an inflation reduction act
and other EU countries would lose out
massively if the EU went down that track
so what our strategy has been is to try
and build a coalition of those countries
that disagree with this trying to
reinforce again well World Trade
Organization multilateral trading rules
work very well with the director General
that to remind people that there is a
better way we can do this in a way that
creates growth for everybody and we've
seen economically that if the growth
only happens in one part of the world
and the rest of the world uh doesn't see
growth it still has an impact on us
whether it's on migration whether it's
on security challenges and um the
willingness of other countries to work
with us and if we are going to have
growth in the green sector whether it's
in critical minerals and so on we need
to work with many of those countries who
will we will be saying no we're not
interested in your um in your industry
but we want to take your your minerals
it does just doesn't work like that but
meanwhile a lot of a lot of potential
green jobs look like they're leaking out
of this country nope I don't think that
is true certainly not at this point and
also we are not as exposed because of
the nature of our industry we're not as
exposed as say the the EU is we've had
some good news from the US in terms of
the way that they will interpret their
rules so some of this can be fixed with
guidance but the truth is we have to
look very carefully at what we are
willing to do are we as you mentioned
steel earlier we're going to subsidize
every single thing we're talking about a
planned economy effectively if we take
all of this down to so your instincts
are very much not about subsidizing um
so
it's appropriate in certain
circumstances so it means going back to
First principles on what basis are we
subsidizing what are we going to
subsidize what are we not going to
subsidize rather than everybody wants a
subsidy let's subsidize it all and hope
it all works out that is not a strategy
and that's certainly not what we're that
Biden you know the White House would say
they've got a strategy here they're
subsidizing certain kind of you know
dirty Industries to become cleaner and
they're subsidizing certain kind of
clean methods of generating power is
that not a reasonable kind of path for
us it is but then look at the ten point
plan I remember when I was with the
treasury we had the 10 point plan and we
gave a pathway for what we wanted to do
in order to um in order to deliver Net
Zero a lot of that work is already
happening some of it is around
legislative certainty uh what we've
talked about with electric vehicles and
so on some of it is around developing
hydrogen carbon capture storage where we
are in terms of geography is very
helpful for many of these Technologies
so there is a strategy there but what we
can't do they're all covered by the
inflation production acts as well so a
lot of those trees are now thinking
maybe it'd be better to be in the U.S
well then The Logical conclusion of what
you're saying is that every com every
bit business is going to go to the US
and set up shop there unless every
country subsidizes when every country
can't afford to do that that is not a
sustainable position
I think it is I think well I think the
U.S at the moment are subsidizing a lot
and we're we're not I suppose the
question is whether that's just a red
line you wouldn't you wouldn't
potentially it's not it's it's not
something well I'm not going to make the
policy um in an interview like I said
I've been doing the job for one day this
is how I've been looking at it from an
international trade perspective in terms
of partnering with with other countries
now that I'm business secretary I can go
away and look at what our strategy
should be uh in well first of all on on
its own terms and then after that in
relation to what other countries are
doing but we are a leader in many areas
we can't always just look at what
America is doing and say well America is
doing this so let's do the same thing
that is not strategic thinking what
you're describing is just copying and
pasting that's not a strategy okay
that's interesting and I mean just
finally
looking at the the state of the economy
as it currently is looking at the the
level of kind of taxes and spending that
we have you said you're not very happy
you know you you're it's the right thing
at the moment for this kind of sound
money your instincts I presume is to try
to get those levels down of course that
was the same Instinct that was held by
Liz truss she's been talking quite a lot
recently do you have any kind of
Reflections about that period in
government what whether you know what
the mistakes that were made were and
well if you listen to what I was saying
in the summer I was saying that tax cuts
you know I wasn't going to get into a
race on tax cuts tax cuts are not a
silver bullet you can't start from there
in terms of creating an economic
strategy what we need to do is something
more fundamental is look at how
government works what the state is doing
are we spending uh on the right public
services are we doing so in the right
way certain things aren't working
anymore and this is uh this is
exemplified by what the Prime Minister
has just done uh yesterday in terms of
talking about a science Innovation as
being areas where we as a country do so
well in specializing let's have a
ministry that's looking at that let's
have a department that's really focused
on those policies because we think that
that's where we can make outsized gains
so just starting with tax as a single
lever which you move up and down can
have adverse consequences but I am
somebody who does believe in low and
simple taxes but in order to get there
you need to create an environment that
allows that to happen simply starting
with the taxes when there's lots of
stuff to do in terms of you know fiscal
and monetary policy more broadly it's
just not it's not where I would start
okay can we read Knox thank you very
much minister of Secretary of State for
business trade but also the Secretary of
State for growth
thank you